I like crushing it and rolling it and
then smoking it what's your go-to food
what are you ravaging duritos Doritos
Doritos is that why my Doritos bins are
always empty could be but you know you
know what I'd go for the The Rice Krispy
Treats that's why those are missing so
you smoke at work I don't but you're
taking the treats at work ah yes do you
have a favorite sense like common sense
just kidding I like touch and taste most
most because when I do smoke all the
other senses are like gone do you like
your team ran I do I love my team what
do you think they'd say if they thought
you were high right now honestly don't
know cuz I don't get high at work oh can
I see your eyes please oh yeah
absolutely so pretty ran are you high at
work right now I'm not great but maybe I
don't know